nah girl on when I saw the trailer for
this I was like a zani premise it's a
cool promise truth or dare
so truth or dare is a new movie by
Balaam house productions as blue house
or blond house one other point as we
know it ruin for a group of college
friends go to Mexico they play truth or
dare with this new guy they meet and
then find out that game is very real and
it follows them back home and now the
game still going on and you don't follow
through with the truth or dare that
you're dared to do funny enough I guess
in truth or dare the truth is also a
dare I dare you to tell the truth this
is in fact you die and now they have to
find out what's happening and how to
stop it maybe the leg is in the
beginning I was looking forward to this
movie because the concept is just
interesting and that's what this movie
is it's one of those movies where you're
like it's a great concept someone gets
that creepy grin thing going on and then
dies got cool and if this movie wanted
to know what angle that wanted to play
that at totally would have work only
thing is this movie doesn't is the movie
a comedy kind of is it a thriller kind
of is it a horror kind of is it one of
those gore movies where you like come on
fail I want to see how you died not
really the deaths aren't really that
interesting because it is pg-13 they can
only do so much fact is it's a pg-13
horror movie about deaths so good luck
if you watch it this weekend everyone's
gonna talk and you know the rule people
who talk in the movie theaters they're
going to hell the conflicting tongues
meters too much like if someone gets
their neck snapped and then someone in
the group just kind of makes a joke
about it I was like alright that didn't
really fit and you're kind of a
psychopath dude got his neck broken it
doesn't faze you at all I know when you
have an ensemble like this there's
always gonna be the [ __ ] character
but in some of these like this where
there's a group and people are trying to
avoid death there might be the one
[ __ ] character but you can make it
work if they're not friends because that
[ __ ] isn't reflective of the group
movies that have strangers that come
together because of the scenario it
works to have an [ __ ] character that
was totally on a different level than
everyone else and you have a group of
friends it's just harder to buy however
as the movie progresses and secrets
start coming out because more people
start picking truth drew starts coming
out you're like maybe you are all ships
I had a point you really stopped rooting
for them you're like I don't know maybe
you're all just dicks in which case my
next crack would be why am i rooting for
them and really I don't go into these
movies thinking it's gonna be a
character piece because it's not nor did
it ever promise to be but before I was
filming this I really had to think hard
I was like wait a minute what how many
characters were there in this movie I
don't know their name so that shit's off
the table but there were
although I totally forgot about them
because they're pretty insignificant in
which case why do you have them oh you
have them for fodder so you can have
someone died because the deaths gonna be
cold no it's not there were a couple of
scenes that did show how good this
premise can be one scene in particular I
was like oh that's actually kind of
irrelevant saying but it never really
hits the mark because the movie didn't
set itself up to be that impactful guys
in the end truth or dare 'it was an
interesting premise and a ridiculous
script and if it committed to its
ridiculousness it would work you take
rampage it was dumb for a lot of the
movie but in the last act they're like
alright we're committing and that's
where you have fun with it this movie
never really found its foothold it tries
to go for this clever ending that really
just kind of leaves you unfulfilled
movies biggest flaw or biggest fuck-up
is the fact they just didn't commit to
an r-rating they committed to an hour
reading movie would have been a bit more
fun you should have some sort or form of
morbid entertainment to fall back on a
movie like this with this premise it has
to commit this movie just rides a line
in the middle it just didn't work for it
I'd like to say be a fun party movie but
I just don't see I just I'm not gonna
remember this one fact I'm not gonna
remember it in t-minus one day ya
already forgot if nothing else maybe
this can be like Annabelle or Ouija
where you can make a sequel or a prequel
with the same premise knowing what you
know sharpen it up and actually make a
movie that's pretty good the very least
more enjoyable there's a truther there
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite movie
revolving around death or the escape
from it we'll go there whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
YouTube still [ __ ] people so if you
ring that Bell
it helps me I love you
[Music]